ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
dans quelques instants vous allez
pouvoir suivre le débat sur les
collectivités territoriales
je vous rappelle que les sénateurs
parallèlement au comité balladur ont
mené leur propre réflexion sur
l'organisation et l'évolution des
collectivités territoriales sous la
direction du sénateur claude belot la
mission belot a donc rendu un premier
rapport d'étape avec 27 préconisations
dont le regroupement volontaire des
communes des départements ou des régions
ces préconisations sont donc présentés
cet après midi dans l'hémicycle
bonne séance à tous l'ordre du jour
appelle le débat sur l'organisation et
l'évolution des collectivités
territoriales je voudrais mes chers
collègues vous dire quelques mots au
début de ce débat sur la proposition de
la mission temporaire sur l'organisation
et l'évolution des collectivités
territoriales nous avons pris
l'initiative de proposer à la conférence
des présidents de prévoir dans le cadre
de notre semaine de contrôle la première
un débat sur l'avenir des structures et
des compétences de nos collectivités
locales nous avons estimé que le sénat
représentant constitutionnelle et
institutionnelle des collectivités
territoriales devait tenir naturellement
toute sa place dans les débats sur le
devenir de la décentralisation est
aujourd'hui je crois que nous répondons
ainsi à cette mission mais aussi à
l'étang des élus mais aussi l attente de
nos concitoyens attachés à la démocratie
locale
nous essayons d'ailleurs éprouvé que le
mouvement se les dire se confirme en
marchant et d'innover pour trouver des
formes de débats qui rend nos
interventions plus lisier plus audible
plus vivante
dans cet esprit nous avons partagé notre
discussion en trois séquences mes chers
collègues
la première pour permettre à l'ensemble
de la mission d'exprimer dans le respect
du pluralisme de son bureau
les orientations de ce rapport d'étape
publié la semaine dernière
bien sûr après l'expression de son
président deuxième étape dédiée aux
groupes qui pourront ainsi réagir aux
propositions de la mission temporaire et
pourquoi pas à celle d'un rapport d'un
certain comité la troisième autour de
1h30 qui sera une séquence totalement
nouvelle pour nous qui s'apparentent à
des questions cribles qui sera une
séquence plus spontané sénateurs qui le
demanderont naturellement dans un
respect des équilibres non pas la
seconde
des groupes pourront demander à
intervenir pour maximum de 2 minutes 30
s ils sont interpellés aussi bien la
mission que le gouvernement pourra
répondre
madame la ministre est ministre on nous
rejoindre dans quelques instants
eux mêmes pourront réagir et ils ont
souhaité pouvoir réagir de la même
manière cette démarche est expérimentale
se demande à sac une et à chacun en
quelque sorte d'entrée dont l'expérience
de faire preuve
j'allais dire d'une certaine souplesse
je pense que nous y gagnerons sans doute
tous nous retrouverons pour un exercice
comparable même si les termes des
rapports de la mission seront sans doute
différent au mois de mai et ainsi
contribuer à cette réflexion lancée par
le président de la république sur la
réforme de la gouvernance de nos
collectivités territoriales je vais en
attendant quelques secondes
maintenant on va voir si c'est
parfaitement synchronisés et c'est
parfaitement synchronisé madame alliot
marie nous rejoindra dans l'après midi
avait retenu avec le président de la
république en ce début d'après midi
monsieur le ministre bienvenus je donne
immédiatement la parole au président de
la mission temporaire sur l'organisation
et l'évolution des collectivités
territoriales président claude belot
c'est le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues
c'est un moment important important pour
notre maison que celui que nous vivons
et je voudrais remercier notre président
gérard larcher d'avoir pris dès que le
président de la république a annoncé sa
volonté de lancer le plus tôt possible
un débat mais aussi une une réforme des
collectivités territoriales d'avoir
immédiatement réagi en disant il faut
que le sénat traite pleinement ce sujet
parce que c'est son rôle constitutionnel
puis que cela lui revient non seulement
de droit mais je crois c'est sa fonction
et sa fonction purement purement et
simplement
avant tout j'ai été désigné pour assurer
le pilotage de cette mission temporaire
je les ai vécues comme un honneur
c'était au moment de la désignation
je vais vous dire aujourd'hui que je l'
ai vécu au chic sommes cinq mois ou
presque mes chers collègues que nous
travaillons on songe pas sous le
contrôle de tous les membres de la
mission comme un moment de bonheur
bonheur parce que je me suis rendu
compte que cette maison était capable
au-delà de tout ce qui peut diviser que
cette maison était capable d'effectuer
un travail d'intelligence
d'approfondissement et aussi de respect
mutuel nous sommes divers par nos
l'histoire nous sommes divers par nos
origines ne représentons la france dans
toutes ses nuances où ces différences
mais nous sommes tous sinon nous serions
pas là pour la plupart d'entre nous
nous sommes tous âges en animateurs
acteurs de la vie locale et nous
connaissons le sujet je me suis rendu
compte que quelle que soit l'origine
géographique quelle que soit l'origine
politique de ceux d'entre nous qui
parlait qui analysait qui essayait de
faire avancer le l'opération ben je me
suis rendu compte que nous avions touche
la même volonté partagée que nous avions
souvent des analyses convergentes et que
nous avons été capables et j'en remercie
tous les membres de la mission a plus
particulièrement ceux qui ont qui ont
agi je dirais en tête de ce travail
conjoint
je pense à pierre yves collombat je
pense rémy pointereau je pense à yves
krattinger super là je pense
jacqueline gourault mais aussi à tous
les autres je pense que nous sommes
arrivés à pouvoir vous présenter
aujourd'hui et ce sont les rapporteurs
qui vont le faire non seulement un
document d' analyse mais cela c'est
c'est des choses qu'on peut qu'on peut
faire mais aussi un document qui nous
engage la mission qui nous engage et qui
sont des propositions votées à
l'unanimité
je crois que c'est important de pouvoir
le dire aujourd'hui
parce que c'est l'esprit qui nous lie
alors le travail n'est pas fini nous ne
travaillons depuis cinq mois
nous avons l'échéance du mois de mai
qu'évite qu'évoque et gérard larcher
et puis nous aurons la loi à l'automne
faudra bien arriver à cela mais ce que
je voudrais vous dire c'est que je crois
profondément à cette maison que j siège
depuis bientôt 20 ans et ma vingtième
année de présence ici j'ai vu le sénat
lui asséna non tout son sens globalité
être capable sur des textes fondateurs
dans des moments pas évident toujours
que j'avais le sénat qui était capable
de se rassembler pour écrire l'histoire
et c'est très important je crois si nous
faisons cela à ce moment parce que cela
veut dire que dans une assemblée dans
laquelle personne n'a les moyens
d'imposer sa volonté
personne ici la possibilité de dire je
ferai passer tel texte ne serait ce qu'à
une voix de majorité
on ne peut pas faire cela au sénat je
dirais que c'est une faiblesse pour
certains mais je crois que c'est une
force
je crois que c'est une force parce que
cela veut dire qu'il ya une écoute de
l'autre obligatoires erna sens que si
elle est réciproque et on arrive et on
arrive je crois à faire quelque chose
d'intéressant qui est conforme à ce
qu'est la france d'aujourd'hui alors les
paroisses les provinces les départements
les communes tout cela se ressemblaient
fort
l'histoire à passer la loi de
décentralisation est arrivée la libérer
les forces créatrices de notre pays
et bien maintenant il faut en tirer
toutes les conséquences mais je crois
qu'il ne faut jamais jamais oublier une
chose importante c'est que nos
collectivités territoriales représentent
aujourd'hui 73 % de l'investissement
public de notre pays qu'elle ne
représente que 10% de l'endettement de
la france
ce qui ce qui veut dire que nos
collectivités territoriales ont été
capables de faire et de bien faire et
dans le sérieux techniques financiers
pour la réussite de notre pays
quelles sont aujourd'hui appelés à
participer à l'effort de relance de
l'économie
je suis sûr qu'elles le feront mais
qu'il serait également utile qu'on ait
le courage
après l'effort de lucidité que nous
conduisons qu'elle est également le
courage de réformer un certain nombre de
choses qui ne sont plus d'actualité
parce que parce que le monde change et
parce qu'il ya un certain nombre de
mises en place qui n'ont pas été qui
n'ont pas toujours été aussi heureuse
qu'on l'espérait puis les hommes n'ont
pas toujours appliquées je pense à la
loi sur l'intercommunalité
les hommes sont les hommes c'est comme
ça mais là il faut il mardi remettre de
l'ordre c'est évident c'est évident il
ya cinquante ans après le livre de
jean-françois gravier le général de
gaulle avait demandé à olivier guichard
2 de traiter le problème il ne pouvait
plus exister paris et le désert lyon
marseille lille était au désert il
fallait fabriquer des métropoles
d'équilibré elles existent ces
métropoles d'équilibré on ne peut plus
les administrés comme autrefois
alors voilà si vous voulez les choses
telles qu'elles sont je voudrais vous
dire en termes non qu après l'entretien
passionnant que nous avons eue avec le
premier ministre edouard balladur qui a
conduit un travail volontairement nous
n'avons pas voulu nous exprimer durant
son travail et avant son expression
publique et bien en le raccompagnant
nous avons eu un aparté il m'a dit
écoutez maintenant c'est vous qui allez
porter l'évolution de tout cela ce n'est
plus moi ma tâche est terminée vous en
ferai ce que vous voudrez ou ce que vous
pourrez mais vous n'avez pas le droit de
ne rien faire
voilà exactement ce que m'a dit edouard
balladur dans la cour du sénat avant de
monter dans sa voiture
je partage tout à fait ce point de vue
et je crois que nous serons ici écrire
une réforme profonde qui mettra en place
un nouveau mécanisme d'horlogerie des
collectivités territoriales françaises
dans lequel nos concitoyens comprendre
en quelque chose et qui permettra et qui
permettra d'arriver à une grande
efficacité
mais il nous faut absolument que nous
fassions tout ça dans la clarté et dans
l'esprit de rassemblement
merci bon
merci monsieur le président la parole
est maintenant à monsieur pierre yves
collombat vice président de la mission
temporaire sur l'organisation et
l'évolution des collectivités
territoriales mon cher collègue c'est le
président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues pourquoi un rapport sur
les collectivités locales de plus est on
tenté de dire
on en compte tant que l'exercice est
devenu un genre littéraire genre
littéraire qui peinent d'ailleurs à
trouver sa place entre le roman
d'anticipation l'essai de stratégie
électorale et le dictionnaire des idées
reçues dans ce dictionnaire à la lettre
c il ya bien sûr collectivités locales
collectivités locales augmentent la
dépense publique voire mille feuilles
millefeuille spécialités du restaurant
du sénat
millefeuille territorial coûte cher à la
france
déploré qu'on ignore combien mais tenez
contre commune produit de la révolution
suspecte il ya trop de communes en
france voire suppression suppression
suppression la suppression des communes
est impossible en france évoqué le
programme de 10 lombard au ministre de
napoléon iii remédier au morcellement
des communes rurales déploré que l'on y
soit toujours pas parvenus compétence
générale
commencez par rothen par rappeler qu'on
lui doit l'essentiel des innovations des
collectivités locales mais conclure en
demandant sa suppression
conseiller général notable conservateur
repérable à la campagne invisible à la
ville conseiller régional recalés du
scrutin majoritaire
invisible à la ville comme à la campagne
département trop nombreux mais proche
des administrés région trop petit mais
éloignée des français intercommunalité
permet des économies d'échelle resté
intraitable que l'observation on ne le
montre pas n'infirme pas le principe au
contraire financement toujours croiser
car version dont le résultat est
d'allonger inutilement les inaugurations
en multipliant les discours réforme
réforme doit être audacieuse marque de
caractère c'est un homme politique
d'hier d'une réforme dont l'utilité
n'est pas établi certes mais elle est
audacieuse précisément la mission
sénatoriale qui vous rend compte
aujourd'hui de ses premières conclusions
en tout cas c'est ma perception s'est
bien moqué d'être audacieuse elle s'est
contentée d'être utile en tout cas elle
elle elle a essayé de le faire quand et
quelle issue de la réforme collectivités
sont encore plus efficace et encore plus
démocratique
d'où la méthode mise en oeuvre n'ont pas
partir d'à priori autant dire souvent
d'idées reçues mais de la réalité de la
pratique de l'expérience si diverse des
élus afin d'améliorer réellement les
pratiques objectif je crois que tout le
monde dise non pas proposer les
solutions déjà en rayon mais les élaboré
par la confrontation des points de vue
exercice sportif s'il en est tant sont
vives les situations et contradictoire
les intérêts exercice intellectuel mais
plus fondamentalement art politique qui
nous dit plateau s'apparente à celui du
tisserand le tisserand qui est capable
de composer avec des files divers un
tissu égales eh bien tu rames et le
titre on est le politique nous dit
platon et en tissant une communauté qui
repose sur la concorde et d'amitié les
tempéraments qui reposent les
tempéraments de la cité à l'évidence une
réforme qui ne seraient pas portés par
un consensus suffisamment large serait
vouée à l'échec
c'est ici pose d'abord de s'entendre sur
la nature des mots
auquel on entend remédier or
l'affirmation lancinante selon laquelle
les collectivités locales dépenserait
trop sous-entendu de maintien de manière
inconsidérée une réduction drastique du
nombre de communes des des échelons
administratifs permettrait des économies
de gestion considérable et bien est une
contre vérité quand les conseilleurs
sont des payeurs avec l'argent des
autres comme le président de bnp paribas
groupes bancaires dont la crise a révélé
la qualité d' expertise comme l'ex
président de dexia sauvée de la faillite
par les états belge et français par
ailleurs auteur d'un célèbre rapport sur
les enjeux de la maîtrise des dépenses
publiques locales ou comme l'ex
président de la berd experts au carré
universel on se passe pour le pont pour
ne pas rire je ne vous rappellerait pas
les des chiffres connus de tous les
collectivités locales réalisent les
trois quarts des investissements publics
et 10% de l'investissement du pays et
les finances d'une manière
particulièrement saine puisque depuis
1982 leur endettement est demeuré quasi
constant est inférieur à 10% du pib
dans le même temps la dette de l'état
qui représentaient 18% du pib en 1982
avoisinait les 70 % avant la crise nul
n'ignore ce que ce sera fin 2009
durant cette période de montée en
puissance de la décentralisation
les dépenses des collectivités locales
auraient progressé annuellement atterri
m de compétences constant 1,4 pour cent
plus vite que les dépenses de l'état
la serait le scandale mais quel scandale
quand on le met en regard avec les
investissements considérables réalisés
avec le développement sans précédent des
services collectifs
durant cette période du début de l'année
4904 des années 90 à l'avant crise la
france a accusé un retard de croissance
annuel moyen de 1 5 point de pib par
rapport aux états unis avec les
conséquences que l'on sait sur l'emploi
sortons un moment de l'épicerie maestri
sienne et demandons-nous qu'on aurait il
été sans les investissements réguliers
des collectivités locales non les
petites collectivités
commencez par les communes rurales ne
nous coûte pas cher en 2007 les dépenses
réelles de fonctionnement par habitant
des communes de plus de 100000 habitants
étaient 78 % supérieures à celles des
communes de 500 à 2000 habitants et 51 %
supérieures à celles des communes de
moins de 500 habitants avec une dgf par
habitant 46 % et 37 % plus élevé que
dans les communes de 500 à 2000
habitants et de moins de 500 habitants
al'inverse ce sont les petites communes
qui investissent le plus celle de ceux
celles de moins de 500 habitants
investissent deux fois et demie plus par
habitant que les communes de plus de
5000 habitants et celle de 500 à 2000
habitants 2,2 fois plus en rappelant ces
chiffres je n'entend nullement comparer
ce qui ne l'est pas je n'ignore ni que
le niveau de service offert par les
grandes communes et pas celui des
petites mais que celles ci ne pourraient
pas investir autant sans aide extérieure
généralement des départements et des
régions ce qui prouve au moins que
financements croisés ou pas départements
et régions ne font pas aussi mal leur
travail qu'on le dit non rien ne prouve
que plus on est gros plus on est beau
l'intercommunalité n'est pas nécessaire
parce qu'elle réduirait la dépense
publique parce qu'elle permet de faire à
plusieurs ce qu'on ne peut faire tout
seul et ainsi de répondre aux légitimes
attentes de nos concitoyens supprimer
les petites communes ne supprimera pas
les moyens qu'elles gèrent au quotidien
les problèmes qu'elles gèrent au
quotidien à un coût minimum aucun des
multiples rapports que j'ai évoquées ne
se risque d'ailleurs à chiffrer les
économies à attendre une réduction du
nombre de communes ou de l'aplatissement
du millefeuille
ce qui d'ailleurs n'empêche pas de
causer la seule étude que je connaisse
qui est tenté d'évaluer l'effet des
politiques de réduction du nombre des
collectivités locales menées en europe
est ancienne c'est celle vous la
connaissez peut-être 10 mai ni je le
cite l'expérience pour le moins mitigé
des pays qui avaient entrepris dès
restructuration radicale les
désillusions du fameux optimum
dimensionnelle ont permis de relativiser
l'absence d'évolution en france les
vicissitudes des réformes à l'étranger
ont montré qu'un concept rationnelle
s'avérer par voie parfois peut
fonctionner
centralisateur et le plus souvent
coûteux qu'il n'existait pas de cadre
idéal pour la mise en oeuvre de toutes
les politiques locales le les gains
potentiels en efficacité et est parfois
mis en échec par l'éloignement
géographique et démocratique des centres
de décision que la diversité locale
était un instrument important du
pluralisme cher aux démocraties
occidentales à la réflexion il apparut
que l'élection de milliers de
conseillers temps des milliers de
communes et c'est encore le moyen le
plus démocratique et le moins coûteux de
faire fonctionner les communautés
politiques et sociales locales
démocratie et efficacité gestionnaire en
effet ne s'opposent pas mais se conforte
d'où la nécessité absolue ne pas séparer
réforme de l'organisation territoriale
et réforme des modes de scrutin
s'agissant des intercommunalités existe
déjà un quasi-consensus on en parlera
je pense tout à l'heure nous en sommes
ne sommes pas encore parvenus s'agissant
du département et de la région
mais je crois possible d'y parvenir en
tout cas c'est sur cette note d'espoir
que je conclurai merci merci monsieur le
président
la parole est maintenant mais monsieur
rémy pointereau vice président de la
mission temporaire sur l'organisation et
l'évolution des collectivités
territoriales vous avez la parole mon
cher collègue monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
en septembre 2008 le président de la
république nicolas sarkozy annoncé
l'ouverture d'une grande réflexion pour
une nouvelle organisation territoriale
partant du constat clair et partagé que
l'enseignement des collectivités et des
compétences dans notre pays est source
de difficultés et de complexité
depuis une commission présidée par
edouard balladur a rendu son rapport
l'ensemble des associations d'élus
locaux ont également apporté leur
contribution
compte tenu de la responsabilité
particulière que la constitution lui
confère dans l'organisation des
collectivités territoriales le sénat a
un rôle majeur à jouer dans cette
réforme et je félicite le président
gérard larcher
d'avoir pris l'initiative de créer au
sein de notre assemblée
la mission temporaire sur l'organisation
et l'évolution des collectivités
territoriales que président
notre collègue claude belot que je
félicite également et à laquelle donc
cette rue cette commission je participe
la première remarque à faire et que la
tâche est difficile
par le nombre et la puissance des
intérêts souvent contradictoires en
cause par l'effet des conservatismes et
des réflexes que ses intérêts génère
chaque élu est naturellement attachés et
toujours pour de bonnes raisons à
l'échelon de représentation qui est le
sien il est temps toutefois de prendre
la hauteur nécessaire pour évaluer
l'efficacité globale du dispositif et
l'améliorer
les français attendent plus de clarté
plus de simplification moins de
gaspillage tout en souhaitant garder une
gestion de proximité
les élus locaux eux-mêmes attendent plus
de simplification plus de réactivité
même quand toutes les strates se mettent
d'accord sur un projet il faut compter
deux fois plus de temps que chez nos
voisins pour le voir aboutir certains
pensent qu'il ne faut rien faire tant
que la crise est là et bien je pense
bien de contraire que l'ampleur de la
crise économique et sociale nous impose
de réformer un système arrivé à bout de
souffle
la superposition de multiples strates de
collectivités sans souci de cohérence et
de rationalité avec des périmètres qui
se chevauchent et des procédures qui
s'entrelacent voir se contredisent est
un frein énorme dans une période
économique difficile qui nécessite
justement de la réactivité
pour autant nous devons aborder cette
réforme avec pragmatisme transparence
esprit d'ouverture et volontarisme et
dire qu'il y aurait des arrière-pensées
électorales dans cette réforme est un
faux procès car chacun sait
qu'elles n'ont jamais réussi à ceux qui
ont voulu réformer dans cet état
d'esprit
plusieurs impératifs doivent à mon sens
être prise en compte dans cette réforme
l'impératif de lisibilité et
d'efficacité
nous devons déterminer qui fait quoi un
impératif de proximité par rapport aux
citoyens car chacun admet que nos
collectivités locales et leurs cinq cent
mille bénévoles sont une richesse
inestimable pour la france de ce point
de vue la suppression d'un échelon de
collectivité n'est pas forcément la
meilleure réponse aux attentes de nos
concitoyens
tout le monde est d'accord pour
confirmer le rôle les communes comme
échelons de base de notre organisation
et de notre démocratie locale
la commune représente la collectivité
locale la plus appropriée et la plus
concrète pour la population d'ailleurs
un récent sondage a établi que le maire
est l'élu le plus apprécié des français
et qui réussit le mieux à répondre aux
préoccupations de nos concitoyens
cependant les communes rurales ont
aujourd'hui de plus en plus de
difficultés à assumer la charge qu'il
raconte mais les communautés de communes
qui se sont développées sur le terrain
ont permis d'instaurer une plus grande
solidarité entre les communes
en mutualisant les moyens de porter des
projets structurant pour le territoire
qu une commune seule ne pouvait réaliser
et il faut affirmer que le couple
communes communautés de communes
fonctionnent très bien aujourd'hui
la réflexion va donc se porter sur le
partage des compétences et des
responsabilités
la clause de compétence générale doit à
mon sens être conservé pour les communes
avec possibilité de délégation
communauté de communes toutefois sur le
mode de gouvernance
je suis opposé à l'élection au suffrage
universel direct des conseillers
communautaires et des présidents de
communautés de communes de moins de
cinquante mille habitants
malgré tout le fléchage des délégués
communautaires sur les listes
municipales permettrait peut-être de
répondre à certaines propositions car
après avoir dit l'attachement des
français aux communes l'élection au
suffrage universel direct des
conseillers communautaires conduirait à
prendre le risque d'un conflit de
légitimité entre élus communaux et
intercommunaux entre maires et
présidents
d'autre part personnellement je pense
qu'il faut achever la carte de
l'intercommunalité avant 2014 concernant
le département et la région
ils répondent chacun à des logiques de
territoire distinctes dont il découle
des missions différentes
de ce fait la suppression de l'un ou
l'autre ou la fusion de l'un ou l'autre
et l'autre ne me semble pas souhaitable
pour autant nous devons mieux coordonner
leurs politiques devenus parfois
concurrentes avec des champs de
compétence qui se sont élargies et qui
font parfois doublons ainsi il me semble
qu'une plus grande intégration des
assemblées départementales et régionales
favoriserait l'harmonisation des
politiques mises en oeuvre et
permettrait de favoriser solidarité
territoriale plus forte entre
départements et régions
mais également de rationaliser les
compétences afin d'éviter que tout le
monde s'occupe de tout et de réaliser
ainsi des économies notamment sur les
dépenses de fonctionnement
à cette fin il doit être possible de
faire exercer aux mêmes élus des
responsabilités départementales et
régionales
ces élus deviendraient des conseillers
territoriaux avec le même principe de
fléchage que celui prévu pour les
communes communautés de communes
certains siégeant département et à la
région d'autres uniquement aux
départements concernant les modalités
d'élection je reste personnellement très
attachée au scrutin uninominal un élu
égale un territoire
on voit bien d'ailleurs que la région
souffre d'un manque de reconnaissance
à cause de cela car le scrutin de liste
à la proportionnelle ne permet pas
d'identifier
les élus d'autre part ils politisent
beaucoup trop les scrutins régionaux et
ne permet pas des élus de grande valeur
le parfois non inscrit un parti
politique comme c'est souvent le cas
dans les conseils généraux de pouvoir
être tenus sur une liste forcément
pilotés par des partis politiques ainsi
un scrutin mixte aurait ma préférence en
zone urbaine on pourrait mettre en place
un scrutin à la proportionnelle car la
notion de canton n'a pas grand sens
le véritable interlocuteur du président
du conseil général étant le maire de la
ville où le président de l'agglo plutôt
que les conseillers généraux et en zone
rurale on pourrait conserver le scrutin
majoritaire uninominal à deux tours ben
des cantons parfois élargi en fonction
de la population concernant les
compétences leur spécialisation entre le
département et la région est
indispensable et doit aboutir à ce que
ses compétences soit exclusive avec
possibilité cependant de déléguer une
compétence d'un niveau vers l'autre sur
la base d'un constat de carence nous
devons ainsi confirmé le département
dans son rôle de garant des solidarités
sociales et territoriales et la région
dans sa mission de stratégie globale et
de réalisation des grandes
infrastructures
il conviendrait par ailleurs d'aller au
bout de la logique des compétences
réunies par ces deux collectivités et
faire en sorte que l'état en tire les
conséquences
en supprimant ce qu'on appelle les
services déconcentrés de l'état qui
doublonnent ceux des collectivités et
bien sûr en transférant les moyens
financiers affectés à ces services
un mot sur les financements croisés que
certains veulent supprimer purement et
simplement tandis que d'autres
souhaitent limiter à deux financeurs par
projet certes cela aboutirait à une
meilleure lisibilité et à une diminution
des délais d'exécution des projets mais
il nous faut prendre garde
à trop de restrictions notamment pour
les communes rurales
ou leurs groupements dont les ressources
sont faibles et qui arrive à mettre en
place des projets importants grâce à ces
financements croisés
ceux qui participent au développement
local et finalement permet par ce biais
une péréquation financière au bénéfice
des communes les plus défavorisés
compte tenu du temps à partie je
laisserai le soin à jean patrick
courtois et à philippe dallier d'évoquer
le cas des métropoles et du grand paris
enfin pour réussir cette réforme nous
devons impérativement repenser les
finances locales
en un mot simplifier le millefeuille de
la fiscalité locale 39000 organismes
décide à un niveau un autre d'un taux
d'imposition sur au moins quatre types
de ressources fiscales
nous devrions je crois nous limiter à
deux types de ressources fiscales par
niveaux de collectivités territoriales
et limiter les cumuls d'impôt sur une
même assiette
nous devons aussi maintenir un lien
fiscal entre les territoires et les
entreprises
l'autonomie financière des collectivités
territoriales doit par ailleurs d'une
manière générale et renforcer l'état je
le rappelle est devenu le premier
contribuable local au travers des
exonérations et dégrèvements adopté au
fil des années par le parlement et les
gouvernements successifs
c'est ainsi que le taux de prise en
charge par l'état des taxes directes
locales a progressé dans le temps pour
atteindre globalement 26% en 2008 soit
20,5 milliards d'euros en 2009 et cette
situation est devenue intenable et
incohérente avec de tels chiffres on
peut prévoir plus d'autonomie fiscale et
une meilleure péréquation entre les
collectivités territoriales pour
conclure l'objectif est bien d'offrir à
tous nos territoires la meilleure
réalisation possible afin d'être encore
plus efficace sans remettre en cause
l'action de l'une ou l'autre
collectivité mais en s'adaptant à un
monde qui évolue de plus en plus vite
cette amélioration attendue ne pas être
uniquement la sphère d'experts et d'élus
les solutions retenues et votées devons
à la hauteur de cette attente ainsi nous
devons refuser le statut quo mais le
pire serait d'aboutir à une demi
réformes sans ambition et sans impact
sur les défauts les plus criants de
notre système actuel
nous devons ainsi faire fi des intérêts
particuliers
nous devons faire preuve de courage
d'audace pour ne pas s'ajouter dans le
conservatisme être finalement à la
hauteur des enjeux auxquels nous devons
collectivement répondre je relève
d'ailleurs que sur les 20 propositions
du comité pluraliste balladur 17 ont
fait l'unanimité parmi ces morts et de
travail dans le cas de la mission
pluraliste sénatoriales se fait
également dans un bon état d'esprit et
sur les 27 propositions 24 sont
l'unanimité il ya donc plus d'éléments
favorables qui nous rassemble que
d'éléments qui nous sépare et en cette
période difficile nous devons garder le
cap des réformes structurelles qui
permettront à nos collectivités d'être
plus performante moins coûteuse et au
service des français
je vous remercie merci monsieur
président a parlé maintenant à monsieur
yves krattinger rapporteur de la mission
temporaire sur l'organisation et
l'évolution des collectivités
territoriales vous avez la parole
monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le président messieurs les
ministres mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
je voudrais d'abord dire qu'il est
difficile de rapporter dans un temps
très court
cinq mois d'auditions de discussions
animées au sein de la mission temporaire
du sénat sur l'organisation et
l'évolution des collectivités
territoriales mais cette première séance
sera suivie d'un autre débat au mois de
mai et le sénat jouera j'en suis
convaincu dans le processus engagé un
rôle essentiel je veux dire aussi que je
vais me cantonner à rapporter le plus
strictement possible les positions qui
ont été adoptées par la mission et je
dois en préambule souligné que la
mission qui a entendu de nombreux
acteurs n'a pas instruits de
réquisitoire contre les collectivités
territoriales elle souligne au contraire
qu'elles sont soumises à des règles
comptables stripped qu'elle finance 73 %
de l'investissement public civil qu'elle
ne représente qu environ 10% de la dette
publique et qu'à l'heure où le
gouvernement les appels à soutenir
l'économie
il faut veiller tous ensemble à ne pas
les déstabiliser
je ne parlerai ni des communes ni de
l'intercommunalité ni des pays
ces sujets seront abordés par mako
rapporteur jacqueline gourault puisque
nous nous sommes partagé la mission nous
avons pu nous accorder très
majoritairement sur un grand nombre de
principes essentiels au delà peut-être
de nos espérances initiales et je vais
essayer de vous les présenter
tout d'abord nous avons noté un
attachement très d'un très grand nombre
d'élus
à la clause générale de compétence pour
le président de l'adf claudy lebreton
qui est présent aujourd'hui dans cette
enceinte et je le cite
elle a permis de répondre à la diversité
des territoires et de s'adapter par des
réponses appropriées innovants et
réactive aux différentes problématiques
locales
elle est d'après l'ensemble des
témoignages une force d'expression de la
liberté des élus elle garantit une
marche de respiration et d'initiatives
l'existence aussi d'un filet de sécurité
elle permet de répondre aux besoins
nouveaux et spécifiques des exemples
récents le montre abondamment
que ce soit pour la téléphonie mobile
que ce soit pour le haut débit pour les
lignes lgv aussi est le plus souvent
d'ailleurs à la demande très forte du
gouvernement
la mission a donc réaffirmé le principe
de libre administration des
collectivités territoriales ainsi que
l'indispensable liberté de coopération
entre elles et avec leurs établissements
publics
il apparaît clairement que cet inter
territorialité doit être encouragée elle
est facteur de progrès les territoires
comme les hommes ont besoin d'échanger
et de coopérer entre eux pour produire
plus de valeur votre mission c'est
évidemment positionner sur les fusions
de collectivités
cette question ne doit pas être un tabou
la mission a retenu qu'un projet de
fusion donc correspondre à un territoire
vécu est relié à des références
historiques sociales et économiques
fortes des espaces ont probablement
vocation à construire ensemble un projet
de territoire et à terme à fusionner ces
fusions éventuelles doivent être
facilité et se réaliser dans un
référentiel méthodologique unique connu
de nos concitoyens
qu'il s'agisse des fusions de communes
de département ou de région
la démarche pourrait être la même
délibération concordante de chacune des
assemblées délibérantes des territoires
concernés
statuant à la majorité et ratification
par un référendum organisé par les
pouvoirs publics à l'issue d'un large
débat
votre mission préconise la même
procédure concernant les modifications
éventuelles à apporter aux limites
territoriales des régions des
départements ou des communes elle
propose aussi une possibilité
supplémentaire soit ouverte de
regroupements volontaires entre une
région et les départements qui la
composent
selon la même procédure que précédemment
les auditions auxquelles nous avons
procédé démontre abondamment que toute
voix autoritaire aurait peu de chance de
prospérer et que toute procédure qui se
rapprocherait de l'annexion d'une
collectivité est de son territoire par
une autre serait vouée à l'échec
il pourrait être proposé aux
collectivités volontaires de travailler
à rapprocher progressivement leurs
politiques et leurs méthodes de travail
avant d'aller plus loin
à propos des compétences exercées par
chacune des collectivités territoriales
question qui fait l'objet de critiques
souvent exagérées la mission a travaillé
à l'amélioration de la lisibilité de
l'action de chacun des niveaux et le
sénat trouvera dans nos propositions des
réponses qui font accord elles seront
dans les prochains mois décliné de
manière détaillée nous devons nous avons
d'abord souhaité définir le rôle
fondamental de chacun des trois niveaux
reconnu par la constitution
la commune et son échelon coopératif
l'intercommunalité dans le lien social
et les services de proximité le
département dans le rôle de garant des
solidarités sociales
et territoriales et les régions qui
doivent être confortée et renforcée dans
leurs missions stratégiques et liées à
la préparation de l'avenir ce qui relève
de la formation des hommes de la
compétitivité des territoires de la
recherche de l'innovation des aides aux
entreprises
les schémas prescriptif aussi ses rôles
étant clarifiée il importe d'adapter les
compétences attribuées à chacun ce
travail est engagé et il progresse il
trouvera son aboutissement dans le
rapport définitif mais pour nous donner
des chances de réussir ce petit
remembrement nous avons à ce stade
retenue quatre principes généraux
d'abord le renforcement des compétences
pour chaque niveau de collectivités
territoriales en vue d'améliorer
l'efficacité et la lisibilité avec
l'idée complémentaire de faciliter la
délégation de compétence
ce qui n'est pas le transfert en cas de
défaut d'intervention d'une collectivité
dans un des domaines relevant de sa
compétence
la mission a souhaité proposer la
possibilité pour une autre d'intervenir
dans le sens de l'intérêt général sur la
base d'un constat de carence la mission
a aussi soutenu la reconnaissance
effective d'un chef de file à pour les
compétences partagées et la mission
propose l'instauration dans ce cas et
pour les financements croisés
das dossier unique d'instruction déposé
dans un guichet unique le service
instructeur devient alors le garant de
la conformité et de la qualité du projet
finalement soutenu et évidemment le
corollaire de la mise en oeuvre de ces
principes tarificateur c'est bien sûr en
conclusion tardive mais impérieuse des
différentes lois de décentralisation et
de transfert de compétences
la suppression des interventions des
services déconcentrés de l'état dans les
domaines transféré
le transfert de leur personnel aux
collectivités territoriales le transfert
aux régions et aux départements dans
leur domaine de compétence respectif des
subventions attribuées localement par
l'état aux communes aux syndicats
intercommunaux et aux intercommunalités
le transfert aux régions de la
responsabilité de répartir les fonds
européens
il n'y aurait ainsi plus aucun doublon
d'instruction sur les services des
collectivités ni avec les services de
l'état la mission appelle aussi à
l'amplification de l'expérimentation à
sa reconnaissance comme outil privilégié
de préparation de l'avenir avec par
exemple mais il pourrait y en avoir
d'autres bien sûr la compétence emploi
qui pourrait être expérimentée assez
rapidement par quelques régions
volontaires seraient ainsi réuni les
conditions pour un transfert de parti du
pouvoir réglementaire aux départements
et aux régions et l'avènement de la
république dont l'organisation est
décentralisée cher à notre collègue jean
pierre raffarin
la révision générale des politiques
publiques qui n'a pas ou très peu pris
en compte le fait territoriale trouver
si elle était adaptée à cette nouvelle
donne des territoires davantage de
lisibilité et de légitimité
votre mission a entendu notre collègue
claude lise claude lise sur le thème
très spécifique des collectivités
territoriales d'outre-mer
celui ci a souligné et je le cite
combien l'enchevêtrement des compétences
et la multiplicité des centres de
décisions sur des territoires somme
toute restreint était préjudiciable à la
lisibilité de l'action publique et à la
bonne gestion des finances locales
la mission a conclu comme lui qu'il y a
lieu de progresser rapidement vers
l'implantation dans chaque département
et région d'outre-mer
là où le périmètre de la sq au fond
avec celui de l'autre d'une collectivité
territoriale unique en ce qui concerne
le grand paris la mission affinera sa
position dans les prochaines semaines
elle considère bien sûr qu'il s'agit
d'un débat essentiel dix ans à trouver
les bonnes réponses aux défis que doit
relever la ville monde
elles mesurent aussi qu'il s'agit d'un
problème très spécifique auquel il faut
trouver des réponses particulières et
l'auditionnera dans les prochaines
semaines les principaux acteurs de ce
territoire pour élaborer une proposition
consolider l tracera des pistes
susceptibles d'être empruntés par le
plus grand nombre pour sa mise en oeuvre
en ce qui concerne le financement des
collectivités locales
votre mission rappelle appel à une
fondation refondation des relations
financières entre l'état et les
territoires
l'état ne peut continuer à intervenir
aussi brutalement et sans préavis
dans les bases fiscales ou les
ressources des collectivités
il est extrêmement important que toute
décision soit subordonnée à une
concertation préalable et fassent
l'objet négociations entre l'état et les
partenaires territoriaux
votre mission s'est aussi accordé sur
l'attribution de deux types de
ressources fiscales par niveaux de
collectivités sur la limitation des
cumuls d'infos sur une même assiette sur
le maintien impérative d'un impôt lié à
l'activité économique pour préserver les
relations entre les entreprises et les
territoires dont les destins sont
extrêmement liés
elle précisera ses propositions dans le
rapport final et elle a intégré que le
rapport valent tout à fait unanimité au
niveau des associations de collectivités
et qu'il était une bonne base du
dialogue à faire fructifier avec l'état
sur ce terrain la mission s'est aussi
saisi du mode d'élection des conseillers
généraux
elle s'est rassemblée sur une chose
leur élection la même année et pour une
durée de six ans s'est demandé depuis
très longtemps à l'unanimité par
l'assemblée des départements de france
cela donnerait plus de force aux
assemblées départementales la mission ne
s'est pas mise d'accord à ce jour sur le
mode de scrutin relatif à l'élection de
ses conseillers généraux entre plusieurs
hypothèses
elle n'a pas aujourd'hui arbitre et le
scrutin uninominal actuel garant d'une
grande proximité entre les élus et les
citoyens dans des cantons bien sûr
redécouper un scrutin de listes
départementales à la proportionnelle
avec prime majoritaire comme dans les
régions garantissant une majorité de
gestion et l'identification de la
personne appelée à présider
nous n'avons pas choisi ne vous énervez
pas un scrutin mixte évoqué tout à
l'heure par mon collègue pointereau
proportionnelle dans les agglomérations
unanime inhalent dans le reste du
territoire dont la constitutionnalité
n'est pas assuré ou encore ou encore
l'élection de conseillers territoriaux
qui pour certains d'entre eux
siégeraient simultanément à la région et
au département
avec avec un fort je vous en prie je
vois que cela vous énerve
alors que je ne faisais même pas dit ma
position alors
avec je le dis quand même un fort risque
de mise sous tutelle de la collectivité
départementale par le niveau régional ce
qui pourrait ce qu'ils pourraient là
aussi être contraire à la constitution
la mission n'a pas à ce jour arbitrer et
je pense que la sagesse qui a prévalu à
nos travaux sous la présidence de claude
belot doigt comme il nous ya invités
tout à l'heure
continuez à nous guider en conclusion
provisoire
je me réjouis comme le président de la
mission du chemin déjà parcouru et des
27 propositions déjà retenu pour la
plupart à l'unanimité et jeudi nous
sommes peut-être aller au-delà de ce que
nous espérions départ je continuerai en
qualité de co rapporteur a travaillé
avec jacqueline gourault au sein de la
mission et avec le président belot et
pierre yves collombat dans le même état
d'esprit et je répondrai bien sûr tout à
l'heure avec plaisir aux questions qui
pourraient m'être posé je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
elle appelle maintenant madame
jacqueline gourault rapporteur de la
mission temporaire sur l'organisation et
l'évolution des collectivités
territoriales vous avez la paire même le
rapporteur j'espère bien
c'est difficile de passer après le
premier à porter monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la décentralisation est l'une des
réformes majeures de ces trente
dernières années elle a permis de
répondre aux attentes des citoyens
elle a encouragé l'esprit de
responsabilité
poursuivez madame elle à encourager
l'esprit de responsabilité des
gestionnaires locaux auxquels ont été
confiés de nouvelles compétences
la démocratie locale grâce notamment au
dévouement exceptionnel des cinq cent
mille élus locaux dont de nombreux
bénévoles dans les zones rurales a donné
aux territoires la place essentielle qui
leur revenait pour la conduite de
l'action publique
les critiques qui peuvent parfois être
formulées ne saurait faire oublier ses
succès incontestable de la qualité de
l'action publique locale
mais justement ces succès important
impose de ne pas céder à la facilité et
ils commandent de continuer à améliorer
l'organisation et le fonctionnement des
collectivités locales dans le même temps
et c'est un corollaire l'état doit tirer
toutes les conséquences qui s'imposent
de la décentralisation est par ailleurs
adapter ses services déconcentrés
c'est à cette seule condition que
s'instaura un nouveau climat de
confiance clé de la réussite de cette
réforme il faut ajouter à la
décentralisation une chose c'est le
développement de l'intercommunalité de
façon accélérée avec la loi chevènement
de 1999
je vous salue monsieur le ministre en
disant les communes se sont appropriés
cet outil souple fondée sur le
volontariat et l'engagement des communes
devant cette évolution du paysage local
et les difficultés grandissantes des
relations financières entre l'état et
les collectivités les grandes
associations d'élus locaux qui sont
présentes ici dans les tribunes réclame
depuis longtemps une réforme que ce soit
la mf la rfl adf
ce n'est donc pas étonnant que le
président et la dcf pardon ce n'est donc
pas étonnant que le président de la
république et souhaitait engager ce
chantier qui l'a confié au comité
présidé par monsieur edouard balladur
c'est dans cet esprit et ce contexte que
gérard larcher président du sénat a créé
notre mission en effet le sénat qui
examinera en premier le projet de loi
s'est saisi de cette question avec toute
la légitimité de représentants
constitutionnel des collectivités
territoriales mais aussi avec la
connaissance experte des territoires le
rôle majeur qui revient au sénat doit
nous inciter à l'innovation et peut-être
même mes chers collègues à l'audace il
ne s'agit pas de tout bouleverser car
nous savons que tout bouleverser ce
serait l'assurance au final de ne rien
changer mais ne rien bouger c'est
l'assurance bien sûr d'une déception aux
yeux de nos collègues élus de tous
niveaux de collectivités c'est avec
beaucoup d'intérêt de plaisir que je
travaille avec mes collègues et que je
suis co rapporteur avec yves krattinger
de cette mission conduite par claude
belot son président je m'attacherai à
vous présenter comme la diva l'instant
les préconisations de la mission ce qui
concerne le couple de la proximité par
excellence que forment les communes et
les intercommunalités les membres de la
mission sont unanimes pour reconnaître
que la commune constitue le socle de
l'organisation locale
collectivités territoriales de plein
exercice
la commune doit nécessairement détenir
la clause générale de compétence
d'ailleurs tous ici nous connaissons
l'attachement fondamentales des citoyens
pour leur commune et tous ici nous
savons qu'il trouve son origine dans
l'assurance qu'ils ont d'être entendu et
de voir leurs besoins pris en compte par
leurs élus en parallèle la
reconnaissance du couple formé par la
commune et l'intercommunalité s'impose
aujourd'hui à tous
nous prenons acte de sa formidable
réussite
une idée nouvelle est apparue dans la
structuration et le développement de nos
territoires
c'est celle de la reconnaissance du fait
métropolitain
immédiatement je voudrais dire que la
mission estime que cette notion de
métropole est limité aux cinq sites
grandes conurbations millionnaire
c'est pourquoi notre mission est attaché
au principe de la création législative
d'un nombre limité de métropoles aux
compétences confort c'est qu'elles leur
soient transférés par les communes ou
délégué par le département ou la région
je sais nous l'avons constaté lors de
notre déplacement à lyon que certains
souhaitent un statut propre de la
métropole
le débat se poursuivra donc sur ce sujet
pour tirer pleinement parti des
potentialités de l'intercommunalité
il nous faut aujourd'hui d'une part
favoriser la rationalisation de la carte
intercommunale et d'autre part
développer et renforcer les structures
intercommunales
la première priorité et d'achever avant
fin 2011
la carte de l'intercommunalité la
mission pense que des incitations
financières négatives pourraient être
utilisés
cet objectif ne devrait pas être
difficile à atteindre quand on sait que
seuls 2522 communes sont en dehors de
l'intercommunalité
aujourd'hui au 1er janvier 2009
et que l'année dernière 5 128 communes
ont adhéré à une intercommunalité
la deuxième priorité est de rationaliser
des périmètres dans le respect de la
diversité des territoires
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire sans
critères de population ou de taille
cette rationalisation doit être liée au
bassin de vie c'est à dire mettre fin
aux intercommunalités de d2 défense
d'opportunités et cetera la fusion des
communautés doit être encouragée avec
des outils souples afin d'éviter que des
situations de blocage ne s'installe
j'ajoute que lorsqu'on le regarde par
exemple le grenelle 2 on voit comment
les communautés sont associés de façon
importante à la réforme de l'urbanisme
ceci démontre l'urgence de cette
rationalisation l'outil que sont les
commissions départementales de
coopération intercommunale les fameux
ces dci pourrait voir le rôle se
renforcer pour déterminer les périmètre
pertinent d'intercommunalité à la
condition cependant que leur composition
soit revue et que leur représentativité
soit améliorée notamment par les
intercommunalités
d'ailleurs dans le même souci de
simplifier l'organisation locale
on doit encourager les fusions
volontaires de communes c'est-à-dire
celles qu'ils veulent celles qui ont
envie en particulier pour les plus
petites d'entre elles et les communes
associées naturellement sur la base du
volontariat
naturellement sur la base d'un
référendum proposé par une majorité
qualifiée des membres des conseils
municipaux des communes concernées
par ailleurs les compétences
obligatoires des intercommunalités
pourrait être renforcé en particulier
celles des communautés de communes qui
sont aujourd'hui limitées en effet il
faut bien reconnaître qu'à certains noms
de communautés de communes
sont des coquilles vides c'est pourquoi
les blocs de compétences doivent tête
minimaux minimale je sais pas enfin
doivent être renforcées je réfléchis
rendu plus pertinente dans ces
périmètres et ses compétences
l'intercommunalité devrait aussi être
amélioré dans sa gouvernance
il est nécessaire de renforcer la
légitimité démocratique des conseillers
communautaires
est ce que prévoit la mission qui est
prévu par beaucoup d'autres annonces et
le fléchage sur les listes de candidats
aux élections municipales
pour ce faire il convient très d'étendre
le scrutin de liste aux communes de plus
de 500 habitants et de mettre en place
pour toutes les communes une obligation
de candidature pour les élections
municipales
enfin le renforcement de
l'intercommunalité devrait logiquement
s'accompagner d'une forte réduction du
nombre de syndicats intercommunaux
il serait procédé par le représentant de
l'état sur avis conforme de la cdc après
une large concertation départemental et
ce avant fin 2012
de la même manière la suppression des
dispositions législatives règlementant
l'existence des pays devrait permettre
de faire disparaître les pays sans
utilité réelle tout en garantissant le
maintien de ceux qui comme notre
collègue breton edmond hervé l'a réclamé
que ceux qui souhaitent sur la base de
la liberté d'association et de
coopération des collectivités locales
puissent exister sur la question
importante des finances locales m'ont
collé krattinger a dit les choses dont
je vais pas les redire ça va raccourcir
mon intervention je reviens simplement
sur un point yves c'est le maintien d'un
impôt lié à l'activité économique
c'est essentiel pour préserver les
relations entre les territoires et les
entreprises
et naturellement ce dernier point
concerne particulièrement les
intercommunalités qui fonctionne sur la
taxe professionnelle unique
il est donc clair
que la réforme de la fiscalité locale
est quelque chose d'essentiel aussi pour
l'intercommunalité
telles sont les préconisations auquel la
mission a abouti concernant le niveau de
proximité qui est celui auquel nos
concitoyens je le rappelle sont très
attachés je voudrais en conclusion son
que notre vous dire que naturellement
non travaux vont se poursuivre un
certain nombre de questions ne sont pas
tranchés ils doivent toujours être
examiné je dois dire que c'est pas sur
le niveau que se présente devant vous
que les questions qui restent en suspens
sont les plus compliqués c'est plutôt
sur la partie je dirais département
région que les choses sont un peu plus
en débat si je puis dire
mais à part ce que j'ai souligné tout à
l'heure peut-être c'est le statut des
métropoles voilà peut-être cela mais je
voudrais vous dire que j'ai été
impressionné en écoutant tous mes
collègues et notamment les élus de
terrain qui sont venus nous présenter
leur situation
je voudrais vous dire que j'ai été
impressionné par exemple par les deux
présidents de conseils généraux de
l'alsace haut-rhin bas-rhin et je me
suis dit en les écoutant
n'est ce pas que parfois les hommes de
terrain sont devant les réalités en
avance sur les textes et je voulais
quand même le dire parce que c'est
quelque chose que j'ai vraiment ressenti
voilà mes chers collègues je termine en
vous disant aussi qu'on entend parfois
et vous devez de l'entendre que moi
l'idée que ce n'est pas le moment de
réformer les collectivités territoriales
sous-entendu et il est vrai que la crise
économique est tellement lourde qui lie
à d'autres urgences mais en même temps
et on l'a rappelé tout à l'heure on
demande aux collectivités locales de
participer au plan au plan de relance
en même temps le président de la
république annonce sans concertation
la suppression de la taxe
professionnelle en même temps
ce sont les collectivités qui devront
j'entends locales qui devront aider nos
concitoyens de plus en plus nombreux en
difficulté aussi ma conviction est que
l'on ne peut pas cloisonner la vie des
collectivités et celle de la nation
chaque collectivité est une essence une
parcelle de la république et participe à
son bon fonctionnement
nous sommes tous ici des élus et vous
savez que si nos concitoyens ne sont
certes pas passionné par la technicité
des débats ils en perçoivent cependant
la logique et la nécessité
le sénat se doit de répondre aux
attentes des élus et de leurs
concitoyens merci madame le rapporteur
pourrait remercier les deux rapporteurs
les deux vice-présidents et le président
pour leur contribution dans la chute du
débat la parole est aux orateurs des
groupes tout d'abord au président michel
mercier pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président
le président de sept ministres et mes
chers collègues il est évident que ce
n'est pas en cinq minutes que l'on peut
faire le point de ce que l'on pense et
chacun sur la décentralisation est ce
que je vous dirais est forcément à la
fois partiel et partial mais et cela
mérite je crois d'être versée aux débats
tout d'abord depuis de la france a fait
le choix de la décentralisation
on peut considérer que de 1982 première
décision
jusqu'à 2003 inscription dans la
constitution que la france est une
république décentralisée
beaucoup de choses ont été faites et que
sans la décentralisation a certain
nombre de politiques avec lesquelles
nous vivons quotidiennement n'aurait pas
aujourd'hui le même succès on peut citer
beaucoup d'exemple on peut citer le
développement de la politique
ferroviaire des transports avec les
régions les collèges et des lycées qui
ont été profondément rénové les
politiques sociales qui ont pris une
tournure plus adapté à la réalité
quotidienne avec les transferts qui ont
été faits aux départements et aux
collectivités locales et que ça la
décentralisation il n'y aurait
probablement pas de rsa au mois de
juillet donc la décentralisation c'est
d'abord un grand succès que nous pouvons
porter tous ensemble et je voulais elle
souligné après nous pouvons
naturellement nous poser la question est
ce que il faut réformer et les choses
est ce qu'il y à une nécessité de
réformer ou est-ce que tout va bien on
voit bien quels sont les écueils qui
sont devant nous il y a eu
s'agissant des transferts de compétences
beaucoup de choses de faites et beaucoup
de choses bien faites et il faut
probablement pas faire grand chose dans
le domaine de transfert des compétences
la question est donc d'abord une
question institutionnelle la
décentralisation s'est fait avec les
outils institutionnels dont disposait le
parlement c'est-à-dire les communes les
départements et les régions
et est-ce qu'il faut changer cela et ce
qu il faut faire un effort tout changer
pour ne rien changer comme l'a très
justement dit van hamme bourreaux se
rappelant sa jeunesse et le départ ou
bien est-ce qu'il faut rechercher à la
fois plus d'efficacité et plus de
démocratie
chacun d'entre nous peut avoir sur ce
point un avis et pour ma part je pense
que soit nous allons vers une vraie
réforme en profondeur qui peut changer
les choses en tenant compte des fêtes ou
bien si on ne fait pas une vraie réforme
en profondeur
il vaut mieux ne rien faire que de
mettre un coup de ripolin en plus nous
en avons déjà mis beaucoup pour ma part
pour ma part je voudrais faire
simplement intervenir sur deux ou trois
points
et pour montrer qu'il y a besoin d'une
réforme en profondeur
je crois tout d'abord qu'il faut que
tout le disions bien haut et bien fort
c'est la fin du paysage unique
on ne peut pas avoir les mêmes
institutions partout dans toute la
france parce que les choses ne sont pas
partout les mêmes et il faut que nous
ayons sur ce point une position la plus
claire et la plus ferme possible la
république n'a rien à craindre de la
décentralisation
elle sera elle même si elle prend en
compte la diversité des situations
locales et il est donc tout à fait
normal qu'on ne fasse pas qu'on ne
construise pas part
où les mêmes modèles institutionnels
mais quand les à date
et de ce point de vue cela peut paraître
peut-être un peu bizarre en tant que
président du conseil général d'un grand
département qui je crois feuilles bien
son travail et il je fais une
proposition qui peut être changera
profondément département mais je cours
bien je suis sûre même que notre pays a
changé à changer en profondeur et que si
nous ne tenons pas compte on passera à
côté de la réalité et la
décentralisation c'est d'abord la prise
en compte de la réalité
je suis donc très favorable à la
création de grandes métropoles 5 ou 6 et
je suis favorable à la création pour une
raison toute simple c'est qu'elles
existent déjà dans les faits qu est bien
le reste monsieur signé fera autre chose
et vous êtes bien habitués comme
d'habitude vous montrer au château où
vous regardez en bas ça nous changera
pas et personne ne vous demande de
changer même ceux signés mais laissez
ceux qui veulent aller de l'avant allait
de l'avant et d'où les seront ceux qui
veulent pas bouger pas bouger mais je
peux donner mon avis sur ce point il ya
une chose que vous n'arriverez jamais à
faire c'est à me faire taire ou à me
déstabiliser dit voulu tout de suite
comme sale affaire est réglée et on peut
s'écouter sans problème
bah oui oui c'est tout c'est toutes les
fois pareil donc on se parle tous les
deux puis apprend ce par tous ensemble
l'afer est réglé je suis favorable à ce
que l'on créé par la loi
cinq ou six grandes métropoles que le
législateur doit prendre ses
responsabilités s'il y a plus d'un
million d'habitants s'il y a des
fonctions de recherche d'enseignement
supérieur les fonctions culturelle des
fonctions économiques exercées par une
grande métropole
il faut que le législateur prenne ses
responsabilités sinon nous aurons comme
d'habitude
paris elle reste de la france c'est pas
cela qu'on veut il y a dans notre pays
deux grandes métropoles capable de faire
progresser notre pays capables de créer
de la richesse autour d'elle c'est pas
une métropole tout seul isolé
elle fera avec les autres et créera une
richesse autour d'elle tout le monde en
profitera
mais ces métropoles elles ont besoin
d'être efficace et elles ont besoin
d'une organisation démocratique que nous
devons mettre en place et pour ma part
j'y suis très favorable
je sais que cette métropole ce sera la
commune que les communes pourront garder
la personnalité juridique de droit
public mais qu'elles n'auront pu toutes
les compétences de la collectivité
territoriale et pour être clair et plus
clair encore je suis favorable à ce que
le département transfert à la métropole
ses compétences quelles que soient les
conséquences
pour moi ou pour nous fait pas le
problème le problème c'est l'efficacité
que nous devons rechercher tous ensemble
cette intervention
cette intervention de c'est la position
et j'ai bien le droit j'ai bien le droit
d'exprimer elle est tout à fait réaliste
parce que je la vis tous les jours
j'ai peaufiné lit tout à l'heure il y
aura tout la poursuivre et monsieur
mercier mais je vais poursuivre je suis
donc favorable à ce que ce soit le
législateur qui s'engagent sur ce point
pour les autres modifications
je pense que le législateur doit mettre
à disposition de l'ensemble des autres
collectivités
une sorte de boîte à outils dans
laquelle très librement les communes les
départements les régions pourront puiser
pour se regrouper s'associer modifier le
paysage et attendre que ce travail de
volontariat soit fait pour que le
législateur au bout de 3 à 5 ans
prennent acte de ce qui a été fait sur
le terrain et légifère pour fixer
définitivement dans le marbre législatif
les choix qui ont été faits localement
grâce aux outils que l'on aura offert à
toutes les collectivités
j'ai bien le sentiment d'être
relativement isolé sur la position mais
c'est pas une raison pour y renoncer
et je voudrais dire que il reste il
reste de très nombreuses questions
très souvent on parle du rapprochement
département région c'est une question
qui est difficile parce qu'il n'existe
pas aujourd'hui de couple département
région il existe un couple département
commune depuis très longtemps il y a des
départements parce qu'il ya des communes
et à 36000 communes
il y a des départements qui assure la
solidarité financière sociale
territoriale entre les communes d'un
même territoire départemental
si demain on veut changer ce coup ça
nécessite un certain nombre de réformes
de transformation probablement elle le
transfert vers les communes de
compétences départementales d'extrême
proximité par exemple une compétence à
laquelle on peut penser c'est celle de
la petite enfance est partagée entre les
communes
les départements mais si l'on veut
transférer aux communes il faut que les
communes aient les moyens il faut leur
permettre si elles le veulent si elles
ont envie c'est à ressentent le besoin
de se réunir et à ce moment là elles
pourront exercer la compétence
transférée du département et peut-être
pour nous regarder autrement ce couple
département comme simplement en
conclusion et on vous remercie de
m'avoir écouté dire que cette réforme ce
débat mérite d'être menée et d'être mené
au bout que c'est une vraie réforme une
grande réforme qu'il faut pas avoir peur
de s'y lancer il faut pas vouloir tout
changer
pas tous le même jour prendre le temps
mais que la décentralisation ne peut
plus aujourd'hui faire l'économie d'une
réforme institutionnelle
si on veut assurer à la fois son
caractère démocratique et son efficacité
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
président la parole est maintenant à
notre collègue devant soi voguer pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
un sénateur du parti de gauche
la parole mon cher collègue monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre chers
collègues sur cette question de l'avenir
des collectivités locales chacun sait
bien que les orientations définies par
le président de la république vise à
réduire leurs interventions
l'objectif masqué de cette
déstabilisation et la reprise en main de
ces pouvoirs locaux de réduire le nombre
et l'influencent de ces milliers de
contre-pouvoir jugée d'autant plus
insupportable qu'il s'appuie sur un fort
capital de sympathie chez nos
concitoyens
cette sympathie prend ses racines dans
les politiques publiques locales qui
sont pour les citoyens autant de
réponses concrètes aux problèmes qu'ils
rencontrent dans leur vie quotidienne et
dans une proximité qui leur permet
d'intervenir sur les choix
or cette liberté accordée aux autorités
locales
pourtant garanti par la constitution est
aujourd'hui insupportable au pouvoir
central
car elle permet aux collectivités
locales d'être des points de résistance
aux politiques libérales de régression
des politiques publiques
alors il s'agit aujourd'hui d'imposer le
chantier d'une rgpp appliqué aux
collectivités locales pour réduire
durablement les politiques et les
services publics
aussi comme veut le dicton populaire
lorsque l'on veut tuer son chien on
l'accuse de la rage
le président de la république qui a
cassé sa volonté de reprise en main par
une critique des mesures et de la
gestion des collectivités locales et de
leurs relations
bien loin des réalités à l'entendre
rien ne fonctionnerait et cela coûterait
très cher ce n'est pas exact entre le
soi disant millefeuille la critique des
financements croisés
l'illisibilité des choix et des
responsabilités ce constat qui se veut
alarmant sert à justifier une remise en
cause totale de l'organisation
territoriale et démocratique de notre
république
cette vision se veut aussi conforté par
le couplet habituel qu'en europe ce
serait mieux ici et que la lourdeur de
notre administration locale serait un
handicap
ainsi dans le domaine comme dans tous
les autres la mise en concurrence et le
nivellement par le bas reste en europe
l'objectif central de la majorité certes
nous avons plus beaucoup plus de
communes que dans les autres pays
mais nous nous considérons que c'est une
richesse
ainsi des centaines de milliers de
citoyens élus se consacrent bénévolement
au vivre ensemble à la défense de
l'intérêt général et la mise en oeuvre
au plus près des besoins des actions
publiques nécessaires il serait
d'ailleurs temps qu'il dispose d'un
statut
s'ils reconnaissent leur mission et leur
permettre de l'exercer quant à nos
régions et ne sont ni plus pauvres ni
plus petit que la moyenne européenne et
le nombre de nos départements et parfois
faible au regard des structures
intermédiaires de nombreux pays
européens
certes en réduisant leur nombre nous
rendrons la taille de ces collective
les plus importantes mais elles seront
alors et aux lourdes à gérer
seront elles alors mieux armé pour
entendre et répondre aux besoins de
toute la population
nous ne sommes pas assurés
permettront-elles le renforcement de la
démocratie locale sur les choix à mettre
en oeuvre
nous pensons le contraire et puis nous
contestons cette mise en concurrence
entre les territoires dans le nôtre pays
et en europe
ne faudrait-il pas plutôt réfléchir au
développement de coopérations de
politique et de service public commun
car mettre en concurrence des
territoires c'est aussi mettre en
concurrence les hommes et les femmes qui
vivent s'est renforcé les disparités et
les inégalités
pour toutes ces raisons nous pensons que
les premières préconisations de notre
mission s'installe dans la logique de la
commission balladur
nous le regrettons d'autant plus que ce
n'était pas son objet avant d'envisager
toute réforme nous pensons qu'il aurait
été utile est plus sage de dresser un
état des lieux partagé sur la situation
réelle de nos collectivités locales
partir des problèmes qu'elle rencontre
de leurs contraintes et de leurs
potentialités
les avancées des blocages rencontrés
dans la mise en oeuvre des lois de
décentralisation et du toujours
nécessaire développement de la vitalité
démocratique de nos collectivités
nous aurions j'en suis sûr dégager
d'autres axes de réformes
aussi nous souhaitons que notre mission
poursuivre son travail dans ce sens à la
lumière des éléments fournis par l'étude
ernst & young pour le compte de notre
mission nous demandons que l'ensemble
des compétences assurées par nos
collectivités fassent l'objet d'une
telle étude détaillée ainsi que les
relations qu'elles entretiennent avec
l'état afin de réorienter les
compétences transférées ainsi que leurs
modalités d'application et de
financement seule cette approche
permettra je le crois de dégager les
axes des réformes à venir car de réforme
les collectivités locales en ont besoin
personne évidemment n'est partisan du
statu quo nous non plus critiquant les
postulats l'origine des travaux actuels
nous considérons qu'il faut réviser
et stabiliser les compétences de celle
ci afin d'ouvrir une phase de
consolidation et de décentralisation
dans un environnement juridique
clarifier et sécurisé cependant nous
considérons comme des préalables à toute
réforme que les trois niveaux de
collectivités locales soient maintenues
sur tout le territoire y compris en
région parisienne et dans les grandes
métropoles pour qui le droit commun doit
s'appliquer sur cette question du grand
paris nous souhaitons que notre mission
se démarque totalement les préco narai
des préconisations du rapport balladur
ainsi que des propositions du ministre
blanc qu'elle soit à l'écouté de la
volonté majoritaire des élus concernés
qui travaillent dans le cadre du
syndicat paris métropole et qu'ils ont
et qui regroupe ce syndicat communes
départements et régions et qui réunit
tous les élus de toutes sensibilités
en ce qui concerne la clause de
compétence générale il faut qu'elle soit
maintenue pour toutes les colis étaient
locales cette compétence générale
c'est le moteur du suffrage universel
c'est elle qui permet l'expression de la
souveraineté à partir des projets
présentés lors des élections locales en
la supprimant nous transformons les élus
locaux en de simple administrateur des
managers et autres compétences définies
ailleurs et dont la mise en oeuvre
serait encadrée par l'état ou par une
autre collectivité
nous sommes convaincus que la libre
administration de toutes les
collectivités locales doit être
sauvegardée mais aussi le respect de
l'égalité des citoyens sur tout le
territoire
dans ce contexte nous sommes favorables
au renforcement de coopération librement
consenti au sein d'établissements
publics ou de tout autre organisme
gérant des compétences délayé ou des
projets communs cependant nous pensons
que leur fonctionnement doit être
démocratisée pour permettre aux conseils
élus des collectivités qui en ce moment
d'être mieux écouter aux populations
d'être associé aux réflexions et aux
décisions
par ailleurs nous considérons que tout
regroupement de collectivités locales
doit être rendue possible
si et si seulement si la souveraineté
populaire s'est exprimé dans ce sens
enfin il ne saurait y avoir de réforme
des politiques locales sans que nous
nous assurions du respect des principes
d'unité et d'égalité de notre république
seul le pouvoir central à la mission et
le pouvoir de les garantir
ainsi nous attendons plus que jamais
qu'il stoppe son désengagement actuel
dans toute une série de domaines en
amont nous attendons son retour aux
responsabilités
laissant ainsi les politiques
territoriales assurer pleinement et
librement leur mission originale au
service de nos territoires et de nos
populations
vous venez de suivre la présentation des
préconisations de la mission belot sur
l'avenir des collectivités territoriales
vous pourrez revoir cette séance sur
notre site internet www.publicsenat.fr
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt sur public sénat